jo leute ich reagiere heute auf etwas
und zwar auf die geisteskranken
hollywood kamerafahrten und ich würde
sagen direkt die erste also hier haben
erstmal ohne sieht aus wie so ein keks
werbung oder die sandwich werbung und
diese einzelnen kekse da haben wir sehen
welche roboter in der hand und das wird
dann quasi uhr wird dann später quasi
alles raus bearbeitet so dass es aus als
würden die aber zusammen schweben ultra
ultra hat sich was das für ein aufwand
ist also wenn wir echt krank allein die
idee zu haben so etwas zu machen und
dann der aufwand einfach so ein
roboterarm an sohn im krieg starb boden
festzumachen heftig direkt in excel wir
sehen hier die silhouette eines mannes
und ok das ist kein neuer untergrund
sondern da sitzt einfach auf einer
parkbank aber in einem tonstudio in dem
studio und jetzt wurde alles weiß es
sieht schon komplett anders aus die
schieben jetzt die lichter war
holy shit sein hemd leuchtet aber weiß
wo mein gott war es das war eine
kamerafahrt ohne schnitt der mit dieser
adam professional gemalt und carolin
woher kommt der anzug oder er hat er den
antrag schon davor an
ach ja telefon weißen anzug und jetzt
auf der vorderseite war ist auf der
interseite weiße anzug und auf der
vorderseite ist ein schwarz und deswegen
hat er plötzlich einen anderen anzug
oder 70 außerhalb eines anderen anzug an
aber es ist trotzdem alles in einer
kamerafahrt gemacht heftig alter okay
jetzt die adam posen und jetzt geht der
arm da unten wo gras das ist heftig
direkt kommt andere stimmung kommt
anrichtete und nimmt er die pistole weg
er zieht sich um kita com jetzt einfach
aber das sind die von der bank die am 1
und das ist gar nicht mein absolut gar
nicht mehr was abgemacht ist alles in
einer kamera zu machen ich glaube die
haben es bestimmt eigentlich öfter als
50 mal probiert bis es funktioniert hat
auf die kids auf die tat reagiert auf
die hat auch schon peter mackinnon
reagiert der link dazu ist in dem video
beschreibung ich habe mir clips extra
noch nicht angeguckt um jetzt auf der
gehen zu können ja nicht hier und da
unten die die szene und oben sehen wir
wieder gemacht wird auch die lassen da
so eine kamera die das sind da oben so
eine kamera im saal runter da dass die
kamera quasi den dude einfach mal
komplett nach unten folgen kann aber die
lassen die kamera gar nicht einfach
unser die können sogar noch vom winkel
herr steuer
denn das ist kreativ oder denkt man halt
0 alter geil auch heftig dass ich die
kamera dann ich irgendwie weg dreht
sondern also stabil bleibt kalt gut dass
apb sehen hier blut das blut fließt in
so ein haufen koks freuen würde ich mal
behaupten und das ziel sich jetzt aber
kommen wir den haufen die kamera fährt
in den haufen koks rein
okay okay die kamera geht hier einfach
rein in den hof hoch und jetzt wo er
jetzt wo jetzt verändert jetzt geht die
kann man sich quasi in diesen haufen
mail oder koks rein das ist quasi der
transition zum nächsten schott aber
nicht einfach nur so billige blende
sondern diese struktur von den koks ist
dann genau die struktur von dem boden im
nächsten clip alter und da laufen also
leute plötzlich durch kritik also das
ist echt schön einfach nur das ist echt
filmkunst ich aber ist wie die das
gemacht haben ich habe vielleicht ein
paar ideen aber echt keinen plan will
ich das umgesetzt haben
richtig geile sachen hier am start okay
jetzt kommt heftige tricks die den
werbungen verwenden
wir setzen hier lässt man gerne
schlüssel in der große schüssel rein und
legen dann nein ja stimmt in der werbung
haben die auf eine suppe immer so zeug
oben drauf was er eigentlich
es wird ja eigentlich untergehen es ist
ja auch nur suppe als erste geil aus
aber das erstens keiner drauf kommt und
zweitens wenn man das macht also wenn
man sowas abzieht also erstens eine
ganze ziemlich geile idee aber wenn man
sowas abzieht kommt man sich da nicht
irgendwie scheint man also kommt man
sicherlich im vorwald man müsste doch
dann denken dass die leute drauf kommt
aber kommen die nicht kräftig sie doch
im vergleich ok pfannkuchen werbung ist
wahrscheinlich also noch macnews.de habe
ich jetzt in deutschland noch nicht
gesehen aber sie legen das papier
dazwischen damit damit die dinge nicht
so suppen die legen eine pappe
dazwischen
nun ist ein sirup ist gar keine arbeit
sondern motoröl ich will es nicht
unbedingt essen bruder aber folgt das
richtig kreativ metzger richtig spannend
so die arbeiten anzusehen okay
die machen einfach bei einer bierwerbung
die macken aber bei der bier-werbung
spülmittel rein damit der schaum länger
hält
da ist auf jeden fall das reinheitsgebot
nicht mehr weil man denkt da gar nicht
dran war müsst ihr mal daran denken
immer wenn ihr irgendeine werbung sieht
von essen oder so das ist in der regel
oder regel aber ist voll oft einfach gar
kein essen die schlawiner alte okay dann
ihren action shot hier geht es dann
weiter nach oben
als ob der kameramann damit rücken wo
war der kameramann springen aber samt
kamera da auch mit runter jetzt will ich
aber mal sieht man hier den shows wieder
dann später aussieht ich will keine
perspektive der richtigen kamera sehen
wie diese tragen
aber das ist echt action es gibt auch so
es gibt doch wirklich sowas ist dann
kameramann wo alles so ich habe mal bei
blaquart dass so eine mitfahrgelegenheit
findung sap jemanden getroffen der
stuntman ist und der war auch mal stand
mein kameramann bei irgendeinem
spiderman film und er musste ebenso 23
meter runter mit einer kamera irgendwie
und das machen die normale kamera männer
nicht weil sind alle so unsportlich
gefestigt und die brechen sich dann alle
was aber ihr seht da in diesem clip da
ist der kameramann ja und rippt der
sieht einfach breiter aus es ist
eigentlich schauspieler wie gehe ich mit
die kamera einfach runterfallen lassen
ich höre dir über verlieren wir sind ja
eine schauspielerin die auf die kamera
zu läuft eine gute kamera hat bisher
aber nichts zur spitze
ist ja noch nichts spezielles oval
moment mal
warte die läuft hier ultra ultra lang
wirklich die läuft hier eine minute
läuft in der minute auf die kamera zu
und dann war das einfach im spiegel und
man zieht in diesem spiel auch die
kamera nicht scheiße
oh mein gott hätte es ist voll die
inspiration und es inspiriert einen
jetzt kraftvoll so richtig geile sachen
zu beobachten und du das ist geil aber
das ist kunst bruder wir befinden uns in
einer stadt die kamera die filme
polizeiautos sowie eine verfolgungsjagd
und wir haben ihn geholt
holy moly was das im film the day war
schlängelt sich einfach so komplett auch
über die anderen autos drüber hollis der
will mich jetzt interessiert habe ich
die komplette straße abgesperrt und sind
das alles nur so stuntfahrer auch die
ganz normalen autos ich höre mir gerne
sehen wie das von oben aussieht also ist
da jemand an diesem abend der den so hin
und her bewegt oder ist es komplett
irgendwie ferngesteuert oder komplett
schon vorprogrammiert das ist unter das
ist echt und regal von gesagt dass der
bewegt diese kennen ja nicht nur die
stabilisierten euro truck rus und
dadurch sieht es eben aus also bitte
keine also komplett durch die straße
durch pflegen damit mich jetzt aber auch
mal interessieren das richtige
filmmaterial von der kamera zu sehen die
das gefühl mal sehen wenn ich schade
china behalte sie in szene die rechts
scheinbar so bis zu einem fertigen
produkt aussehen und links hier sei es
okay warte herrgott seht ihr links was
sie alle machen dieses team veränderte
mal das komplette zimmer der kameramann
geht es auf dem fernseher darauf dass
man den rest nicht mehr sieht und dann
geht aber wieder zurück und dann ist
einfach alles anders die arbeiten die
ganze zeit hinter der kamera
oh mein gott kaum ist der kammer
kommissar kameramann aus dem winkel
draußen sind da schon 1000 arbeiter die
da alle herum wuseln wieso kleine
ameisen okay erklärt allerdings anders
komplett an der die schauspielerin
wieder rein
licht ändert sich jetzt auch krass jetzt
haben wir
[Musik]
teelicht komplett verändert ich weiß gar
nicht welche seiten konzentrieren soll
die verändern die ganze zeit alles und
jetzt das lichtbild verändert und jetzt
ist er jetzt ist es ein
flachbildfernseher können alle
erhältlichen bild oh mein gott war es
der seite kommt wenn ihr mal meine möbel
so schnell bringen würden sie räumen der
einfluss von der möbel wand aufräumen
gefühlt rein und da wieder die
richtwerte sind komplett verändert alles
an die sparkasse lampen darin auch gut
was war das für ein geiler kameramann
auch die geil diese taten sind
das ist ein anteil der kameramann nach
zone geile arbeit hier und das ganze
team macht zu unter die koordinierte
arbeit wie lange das noch dauern muss
das alles ein zu choreografieren und das
ist ja oh mein gott zu aufwendig für so
eine szene dann wo man sich zu einem
kino hinter denkt hey werden die das
gemacht weil man denkt ich hatte ja nur
treffen die schnitte gemacht hat ja gar
nicht null kein einziger schmidt ein
kleiner fehler ein kleiner fehler und
ihnen alles nochmal komplett neu machen
und ich bin mir sicher die haben das 50
mal gemacht und am ende ist dann
irgendeiner irgendwie gestolpert oder
hat dann irgendwas liegengelassen
auszusehen und dann musste alles
komplett neu machen
ok badleiterin amerikanisches bier weil
er wurde das ist gut weil die handkamera
roboter wie wird ich filmte das was das
für die kamera das startet das
stabförmigen all das ist so kann man
denkt so hell wie die kriegen die eine
kamera zwischen diese dosen ich dachte
am anfang ist er einfach 3d animiert
also wirklich dachte sowas ist 3d
animiert weil müsste man denken es wäre
vielleicht wird die haben einfach eine
richtig geile kamera und dann richtig
langes dünnes positiv drauf gestellt
dann sieht es aber so aus als wäre der
betrachter jetzt quasi nicht hinten bei
der kamera sondern also vorne an der
speziellen sowie twilight
ok heftig das war wohl teil krasser
treten und wenn ihr als inspiriert zeit
selber zu schneiden und hab ich kreativ
zu werden ich habe es gemacht indem ich
euch das schneiden beiträge mit also für
ihr projekt auf den ersten link in der
beschreibung da könnt ihr euch den
überblick anschauen und dann könnt ihr
entscheiden könnt oder eben nicht aber
diese clips alternativen ja mal so
heftig die echte also hätte ich die nur
gesehen und hätte ich gedacht dass alles
einfach 3ds aber das ist dann nicht
sinnvoller ist sogar sagen wir in echt
zu machen mit einer krassen choreografie
geil alter richtig geil hat spaß gemacht
diese clips anzuschauen
ich hoffe ihr den auch spaß wie gesagt
mein kurs ist in der video beschreibung
wenn ihr schneiden lernen wollt
instagram ist auch in dem video
beschreibung und wenn er mich auf diese
reise begleiten möchte dann lassen wir
gerne abo da und dann sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]